مرور 100 يوم على الحرب على قطاع غزه ما
تزال مشاهد القصف القتل الدمار ماثله هنا
امامنا لم يتغير شيء سوى الايام التي تمضي
مثقله بالمتاعب وبالهم وايضا بمزيد من
التشرد والقتل والدمار هنا في مدينه رفح
جنوبي قطاع غزه غار على منزل في مخيم
بربره للاجئين الفلسطينيين كما تشاهدون
امامكم هذا هو المنزل الذي قصف من قبل
الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي الذي اتى على
اركان هذا المنزل دون سابق انذار بطبيعه
الحال هذا المنزل عندما قصف كان الناس هنا
نيام في طبعا المنزل بطبيعه الحال عندما
قصف من قبل الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي
ونجاه هذه العائله باعجوبه ما بين يعني
مصاب بجراح طفيفه ومتوسطه وخطره نقل الى
مشافي مدينه رفح هنا جنوبي قطاع غزه هذهه
يعني احدى حفر الصاروخ التي اخترقت سقف
هذا المنزل
وا بطبيعه الحال نزل الصاروخ الى سقف اخر
هنا في هذا المكان وكان الناس نيام هنا في
هذه الغرفه علكم تشاهدون حجم هذا الدمار
امامكم الحمد لله على سلامتكم بدايه ما
الذي حدث معكم هنا هذه الليله الله يسلمك
بدايه احنا الساعه تقريبا الساعه ين وربع
صباحا نعم فجاه سمعت صوت
ابني مسكني من ايدي بيقوللي يابا انت كويس
قلت له انا كويس ابني الثاني بيقوللي يابا
القصف في دارنا بقوله يابا بس احنا
كويسين اللي هو بقول لا في دارنا الحين
انا قلت استنى شويه في الغبره والميه صوت
الميه والغبار والشظايا قعدنا تفقدنا
ايدينا وحالنا لقينا حالنا الحمد لله
كويسين فقمنا شوي نتفقد بعضنا ولقيت يعني
في تقف في في سطح
المنزل و هذا احنا حالنا زي حال الناس
يعني في على مستوى ق ك نايمين في غرفه
واحده في كنا نايمين في غرفه واحده انا
وابني محمد
ومهند وفجاه صار القصر بدون سابق انذار
ولا اتصال ولا اي حاجه يعني ومما تسبب في
الشزاي على المخيم
و واصابات اصابات كثيره واصابات وتم
تحويلها لمستشفى الكويت الحمد لله رب
العالمين نلقي نظره هنا على هذا المخيم
المقتضي في هذه المنطقه الواقعه في وسط
مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه هذهه حتى
المنازل المجاوره هي من الصفيح بطبيعه
الحال لحق بها الدمار والضرر والقصف
الاسرائيلي كما تشاهدون هنا امامكم في هذا
المشهد هاني الشاعر لقناه الجزيره مدينه
رفح